this is what many villages in sudan's
southeastern ghadari state look like
days of torrential rains and the
seasonal flooding of the rahad river has
submerged homes
many have collapsed leaving residents
with nothing
the water came and flooded us and took
everything we used to have many books
but all of them are gone we lost our
savings food and furniture we have
nothing but to thank god
more than 4 000 homes have been
destroyed in 23 villages near sudan's
border with ethiopia most have been cut
off for nearly three weeks
authorities in the western ghalabat
region have provided some assistance but
it's nowhere near enough and they have
broadened their appeal describing the
situation as catastrophic
the directorate of health in the state
of ghidaraf provided medicines and
blankets
also the state emergency committee
provided what assistance it could
but it's not sufficient compared to the
size of the disaster
we urgently appeal to all sudanese
people to help us as well as
international organizations
[Music]
several people died when the raha river
burst its banks and hundreds are
displaced these families have found
shelter in a school it's only temporary
and although it's dry it lacks basic
necessities
we are in a very difficult situation our
children can barely survive here we need
tents food and water we need medicine
our children are suffering as we don't
have
large swaths of agricultural land are
waterlogged and livestock have been
swept away raising concerns of an
outbreak of disease and an environmental
disaster the raha river floods every
year but people here say this is the
worst they've seen in three decades
heber morgan al jazeera